Hi there, Steve Kaufmann here.
Today I want to talk about habits,
habits of a lazy language learner.
Remember if you enjoy these
videos, please subscribe, click
on the bell for notifications.
Yeah, I want to talk about my
language learning style now.
Uh, and what I would call being a
lazy language learner, which doesn't
necessarily mean that you aren't
being a successful language learner.
It just means that you're being
lazy the way I'm being lazy.
And so there are seven habits I think
that we need to acquire if we're going to
be effective, successful, lazy language
learners, the first is to set low goals.
Okay, so on my 90-Day Challenge, I've
set my goal for creating LingQs at
13 for Arabic and 13 for Persian.
And there was a time when I was
trying to do a hundred new LingQs
in Arabic, Persian, and Turkish.
It was simply too much.
Um, so I've changed my style.
Now I set low goals.
Now I regularly exceed these goals
if I look at my statistics, but
the low goal just gets me going.
I don't see, you know that I, I
don't feel any great burden or
obligation I just get started.
And once I'm launched, I'll
generally, you know, exceed my goals.
But my first habit therefore,
is to set low goals.
Now I have a bit of a cheat sheet here
and I'm going to make sure I don't forget.
The second thing is don't
compete with others.
I'm not competing with other people.
Uh, in my challenge, I'm not
comparing myself to others.
Some people are going faster.
I see that I'm ranked 1,572 on my streak.
That's fine.
Uh, some people are going
to pronounce better.
Some people are going to learn
faster, slower, whatever.
It doesn't matter, I'm
learning it for myself.
So I'm not competing.
It reduces the stress level.
Anything that reduces the stress
level makes learning more enjoyable,
makes learning more effective.
The next thing is to be a lazy
language you've got to go with the
flow, do things that you want to do.
For example, uh, I'm on my Arabic and
Persian challenge, but lo and behold, my
wife starts watching a Danish series on
Netflix and I love listening to Danish and
there's lots of words I don't understand.
So I say, I'm going to do a bit of Danish.
So I spent a day out of my week or
more listening to the mini stories
in Danish, uh, Hans Christian
Anderson stories in Danish, uh,
saving a bunch of Danish words.
So that I have some sense of some
of these words that I hear in this,
uh, TV series called The Sea View
Hotel that I don't understand.
And now I understand that a lot better.
Uh, similarly I started watching
an Egyptian movie for fun.
So follow your wishes.
And I guess that ties into the fourth
habit of a lazy language learning
learner, and that is treat language
learning as a form of entertainment.
Okay, and include entertainment.
So obviously, when I watched the Danish
series, I understand a lot of it.
And by doing a little work on LingQ,
I understand a lot more, uh, with the
movies, the Egyptian movies, I'm speaking
with my tutor or aat least we're going
over the mini stories in Egyptin Arabic,
which is different from standard Arabic.
And my hope is that I'll understand
Egyptian movies better, but watching
an Egyptian movie, like the movie I
saw, I think it's called, uh, Asmaa uh,
about a woman who has AIDS in Egypt.
I can enjoy the movie.
I get the...
I hear the language.
I don't really understand much of
it, but it's a form of entertainment.
It brings me into the culture,
language learning is...
should be entertainment as well.
It shouldn't just be routine and
drills and that kind of thing.
So allow yourself to be entertained.
Um, another thing about being a lazy
language learner is I don't prepare
for my sessions with my tutor.
I don't prepare, I just show up, um, with
Mohammed and Egyptian Arabic, we just
open up a mini story, I read a bit of it.
Then maybe we have some questions on it.
Then we fade into a
discussion of something else.
In Egyptian Arabic or in Standard Arabic
more, if we're free conversation, it's
more Standard Arabic than Egyptian Arabic.
I struggle in both, but I don't prepare.
I just show up and, and again,
whatever exposure I get, whatever
I'm doing with the language, engaging
with the language during that hour
with Mohammed is all to the good.
So no need to get hung up about preparing
for the session, lazy language learner,
you just show up one-on-one and benefit.
Another important...
number six habit of a lazy language
learner is when you're tired of doing
something, go and do something else.
Introduce is a lot of variety.
As long as you are engaging with the
language you are achieving something.
So you're tired of listening,
go do more reading.
I sometimes feel I have to push
myself a little bit on the reading
because I think the reading is, is
essential to acquiring vocabulary.
Uh, obviously the listening is easier
to do while I'm doing other chores,
um, but uh, introduce movies and
switch from one language to another,
uh, introduce variety around it.
Keeps it interesting.
You have less of a sense that
you're constantly sort of
pounding on the same door.
Variety keeps things interesting.
Enables you to be a lazy language
or, and the final seventh habit
of a lazy language learner is
in a way don't measure yourself.
Don't compare yourself to what you did
before or where you would like to be,
or what other people do don't measure.
Accept the fact that
the process is success.
Success is the fact that you are engaging
with the language, accept the fact
that whatever you're doing as a lazy
language learner, it is helping you.
It is helping the brain
get used to the language.
Some days you would like to be better.
Some days you're better
than you thought you were.
Uh, sometimes you feel you have achieved
a lot over the last three months.
Some days you feel you're treading water.
It doesn't matter.
The fact that you are engaging with
the language is in itself success.
The fact that you are enjoying the
process, the fact that you are continuing
to get involved with the language,
listening, reading, watching movies,
speaking, whenever you're doing that
is that that makes you successful
because you're continuing to do it.
And if you continue to do it, and if you
enjoy the process, even as a lazy language
learner, you will reach your goals faster
than, in my opinion, forcing yourself
to do things that you don't want to do.
So there you have the seven
habits of a lazy language learner,
which I consider myself to be.
Although I do spend a lot
of time with my languages.
Bye for now.